[Music]
the breath of the wilds final act the
champions ballad links ancient allies
get their chance to retake the spotlight
the result is less impactful to the
overall story that we are already
familiar with but the accompanying
quests and new gear do a lot of the
heavy lifting delivering over a dozen
new stages to test your problem solving
skills and evermore interesting ways
they alone make a return trip to hyrule
worth getting excited about but you must
first prove yourself worthy of the
opportunity upon returning to the
resurrection chamber at the start the
cave where link awoke from his 100-year
slumber you're given a weapon known as
the one-hit obliterator as the name
implies this short range weapon allows
you to kill an enemy in a single blow
but with your health consequently little
down to our quarter heart you're also
more vulnerable than ever you may have
shrugged off an occasional bee sting
before but it's little incidents like
these that now teach you to think twice
about every move you make sadly it's a
great setup that ends too soon after
clearing out for small enemy camps and
the shrines that emerge from their
defeat the weapon returns to the
resurrection chamber having fulfilled
its duty even after completing
everything the DLC has to offer the
weapon remains unusable which feels like
a missed opportunity
but with this stage of the journey not
complete you're sent off to the four
corners of Hyrule on a glorified
scavenger hunt in a very pleasing way
the goals set for you take great
advantage of breadth of the wilds
numerous mechanics you will take on
snowboarding challenges that tasks you
to pass through rings in a limited
amount of time hunt Hyrule's elusive
dragons and re-engage the banana loving
mega clan among other missions that test
the breadth of your capabilities and for
each task you complete a new shrine
surfaces from underground the champions
shrines forced you to engage in
mindfulness and critical thought they
typically involve a lot of moving pieces
during away from combat in favor of
puzzle solving so far removed from a
life of shrine hunting in the main game
returning to these creatively built
challenges takes you back to a time when
breath of the wild was this new and
mysterious thing and experience filled
with surprises upon completing the three
shines in a given set you're able to tap
into memories of the relevant champion
you don't get the opportunity to
directly control Hyrule's famous
defenders but as link you reenact their
battles against Ganon's for blights the
same for bosses you fought at the end of
the games to find these dungeons the
difference this time around is that
you're limited to a small selection of
gear based on what each champion would
have carried into battle oddly you
retain access to the powers bestowed to
you by the
ian's spirits in the past which gives
you incredible advantages and somewhat
negates what would otherwise be
difficult battles you can always turn
these powers off if you choose but given
the context of exploring someone else's
memories it would have made more sense
had they been disabled by default your
immediate reward for beating each blight
is the ability to recharge champion
abilities in less time and new cutscenes
for each champion each one shows a
recollection of when they were recruited
to join Zelda's anti Ganon squad a
hundred years in the past these
vignettes are more playful than serious
which is a little disappointing
considering the gravity of the calamity
they're up against but thankfully
there's a bigger and better reward
waiting for you once you've resolved
every champions quest a new divine beast
dungeon complete with a totally
surprising boss fight in a similar
fashion to other divine beasts the final
station requires you to manipulate the
entire structure rotating major
components this way in that as you work
to resolve four puzzles locking away the
final area the scope of the final divine
beast like the ones before it is
delightfully difficult to wrap your head
around both for how big it is and how
ornate is solutions are the parting gift
for your efforts is one of the
unlikeliest additions to the Legend of
Zelda an ancient motorcycle loosely
modeled to resemble a unicorn Lynx new
bike fits thematically if not logically
into breadth of the wilds mythical
tapestry on one hand having a bike at
the ready overshadows your stable of
horses but on the other tearing through
jairo on a motorcycle is it as
ridiculously playful as it sounds it
even makes for a fun snowboard
replacement on snowy hills which helps
escalate the sense of speed as you rock
it down mountains and look for ramps to
catch a bit of air
the only real disappointment you can't
some of the motorcycle in the desert nor
travel there if you're already on the go
attempt the ladder and an invisible wall
prevents you from proceeding exactly the
same as if you tried to enter on
horseback who knows if Nintendo will
continue to surprise us with fanciful
new additions to breadth of the wild
down the road but considering that
champions ballad is likely the final
word on this chapter in the Legend of
Zelda it's a bittersweet goodbye there
are so many wonderful quests and
beautiful tiny moments that make
revisiting Hyrule feel like reliving
your own memories when breadth of the
wild was truly new and surprising
Nintendo certainly could have extended
some of the aspects within the champions
ballad such as giving you access to the
obliterator at any time and letting you
ride your new motorcycle over sandy
dunes but these are minor blemishes an
otherwise great trip down memory lane